90
is the percent chance that if you
self-administer one of the now widely
available home cova tests in england
and you get a positive result that that
positive is false
ninety percent false positive rate of
these self-administered tests that are
um now being widely used why they
distribute it as if i think it was april
9th
um and which the results of which are
being used to decide whether or not you
have to quarantine and thus
lose you know work school life
everything opportunities
so oh boy
this sounds really cocked up
this is british right is that british
yes
okay that doesn't sound british to me i
just guess
i deliberately used my most american
accent for it but
it's mighty cocked up if i'd said that
you would have spotted right away that
it was a british
okay so there's an article in the
guardian on this um
and i'll have you put it up in just a
second zach but um we discussed
many episodes ago i did not have time to
go back and figure out which episode or
episodes it was in
the risks of false positives in testing
and you know no matter
and and when the first i think it was
when the first
i don't remember i don't remember what
exactly the context was but we were
talking about how
as disease prevalence falls the
proportion of people who are tested who
receive false positives goes
up and so you have a situation um
especially in the parts of england where
this is taking place
um where background rates are understood
to be quite low where the false
positives are particularly high and it's
having therefore you know
in exactly the place where the disease
is the least risk
you have the highest proportion of
people who are suffering costs that they
should not be forced to suffer
especially after
13 months of this so let's just give
people the uh the logic that makes it
easy to deduce okay
in a case where you're testing for a
disease that is
if you were to test for smallpox right
a hundred percent of positives are false
right because there's no smallpox
anymore
so um as the disease prevalence falls
the percentage of those who get a
positive uh
that is false it goes up for this weird
reason
so um so anyway what does this do to us
in the case where you've got a low
prevalence of covid
in britain and uh a test that is now
being
how frequently do you say it's being
administered um
well here i'll read you two paragraphs
from this from this piece
in one email ben dyson an executive
director of strategy at the health
department and one of health secretary
matt
hancock's advisors stressed the quote
fairly urgent need for decisions on the
point at which we stop
offering asymptomatic testing so this is
basically expected that the entire
population is doing this asymptomatic
testing reliably in order to
get back to normal which we all want
quote on the 9th of april the day
everyone in england was able to order
twice weekly lateral flow device tests
these are lfd tests dyson wrote as of
today
someone who gets a positive lfd result
in say london
has at best a 25 chance of it being a
true positive
but if it is a self-reported test
potentially as low as 10 percent
on an optimistic assumption about
specificity or as low as
two percent on a more pessimistic
assumption so that rate of false
positives
is from uh 75 to 98
um on these tests that are being that
they want people to be doing all the
time and you know of course you've got
one yeah one person
who is now doing this twice a week for
many weeks um
is is not does not even have just
you know if they get a positive
they are increasing their chances of
getting any positive and their chances
of that positive being false are 75 to
98
depending and because they're having to
take more and more tests the chances of
them getting a positive are higher right
now
there are a number of things we want to
know in order to figure out whether a
reasonable
policy could be rescued out of a test
that's this bad right right so
one thing you want to know is does one
false positive
predict other false positives in the
same person right right
if it was true that any given test could
throw a false positive but then if you
took a second one
uh it would be likely i think the answer
to that if that it would be likely to
not give a false positive
i think that is like the case because
they're talking about um
it sounds like they're talking about
doing that but of course then you've got
double the number of tests well no you
don't have to have on there
you you have you you have to follow up
with anyone who's got it you have to
follow up and you traumatize people who
oh my god i got a
positive covet test do i have kovid um
so anyway
there's also the question the on the
good side the reason that you might
deploy a test
this bad is that if the false negative
rate is low
then those with covid will be in the
sample of those who test
positive even though most of those
people are negative so
you could if your point is we have to
stop kovid from spreading
and the point is within the small number
of people who get a positive test
most of them don't have covid but
everybody who has covet is in that
sample too
then you could behaviorally shift things
around those yes
it could function but you would want to
be very clear with the public don't
freak out
when you get a positive test take
another one assuming that a second one
is not predicted to give you another
false positive yeah
and the you know if the second one is
negative you don't have it which would
be true if the false negative rate was
low
so you could rescue a policy out of this
but
on its own that's just a shocking number
of false positives
yeah it sure is
[Music]